es ist die mutter aller katastrophen
supervulkan können jederzeit ausbrechen
und einer katastrophe mit globalen
folgen auslösen eine neue studie kommt
jetzt zu alarmierenden ergebnissen
demnach sind super vulkane nach einem
ausbruch noch jahrtausende gefährlich
womit die bisherigen annahmen für die
vorhersage solcher mega eruption wohl
falsch sind und eine methode das
schlimmste zu verhindern könnte die
katastrophe womöglich auslösen klicks
umsatz im future hier gibt es einmal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los ist
herzlich willkommen der option von
supervulkan gehören zu den dramatischen
ereignisse in der erdgeschichte
gigantische mengen an lava schießen dann
aus der erde und das kann verheerende
globale folgen haben beispielsweise auf
das globale klima nach einer mega
eruption kann die erde in einem
sogenannten vulkanischen winter fallen
gemeint ist damit ein langer und
ungewöhnlich kalter zeitraum der das
leben auf der erde fast unmöglich macht
das große problem trotz intensiver
forschung tappen fachleute weltweit im
dunkeln wenn es um die vorhersage
zukünftiger ausbrüche von supervulkan
geht immer noch nicht ist die
wissenschafts community in der lage die
tatsächliche gefahr präzise und
detailliert zu überblicken ein
internationales forschungsteam hat einen
alten supervulkan in indonesien
untersucht und warnt davor dass unser
unwissen dramatisch ist der aktuellen
studie zufolge ist die gefahr die von
supervulkan ausgeht auch noch
jahrtausende nach einem ausbruch enorm
hoch zudem fordern die fachleute ein
umdenken was die vorhersage dieser
potenziell katastrophalen ereignisse
angehe alle wichtigen facts zu dieser
spannenden studie gibt es jetzt hier bei
pixum science in future einer der
faszinierendsten und wohl auch
gefährlichsten super vulkane ist der
supervulkan unter dem amerikanischen
yellowstone nationalpark er ist wirklich
gigantisch seine magma kammer ist 40
kilometer breit und 6 sich kilometerlang
und ihr brodeln
15.000 kubikkilometer magma eine riesige
gefahr und keine frage falls der vulkan
ausbricht hätte dies fatale folgen für
die menschen auf der gesamten erde ein
horrorszenario
vor allem für die us staat montana
wyoming und die gesamten
nordamerikanischen kontinent der
ausbruch des yellowstone vulkans wurde
blut lavigne aus lava und asche mit
einer temperatur von 800 grad celsius
niedergehen lassen infrastruktur und
landwirtschaft hätten keine chance mehr
die sonne kommt nicht mehr zur erde
durch wolken aus schwefel gas würden
dies verhindern das globale klima kühlt
ab und die ernten in zahlreichen
regionen weltweit fallen aus 74 tage
lang würden uns die weltweiten
nahrungsvorräte wohl überleben lassen
danach würde wohl ein großteil der
menschen verhungern fachleute sind sich
schon lange sicher dass das komplette
leben auf der erde durch einen ausbruch
des super vulkans bedroht wäre deutlich
macht dass auch einmal das alarmierende
statements des nasa mitarbeiters brian
wilcox demnach seit die forschung zu
supervulkan weitaus wichtiger ist um die
menschheit vor gefahren zu schützen als
die entwicklung von systemen die kometen
und asteroiden von der erde fernhalten
und so haben forschungsteams weltweit
den supervulkan im
yellowstone-nationalpark ganz genau im
blick um auch ja jede kleine veränderung
registrieren zu können statistisch
gesehen wäre der schlummernde vulkan
jedenfalls überfällig die drei
bisherigen ausbrüche passierten vor 2,1
millionen jahren vor 1,2 millionen
jahren und vor 640.000 jahren der
geologische dienst der usa united states
geological survey aber geht nicht davon
aus dass eine größere eruption in der
nächsten zeit zu befürchten sei doch
vielleicht wird er sich laut der neuen
studie denn seiner ansicht nach müsse
sich der untergrund in der region stark
verändern ein drittel der markt kammer
müsse geschmolzen sein damit sich der
bvi flüssigkeit verhält messungen aber
zeigen dass derzeit weniger als ein
zehntel des gesteins flüssig ist demnach
sei das magma gegen einzelnen blasen in
fels poren eingeschlossen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass eine große
eruption das super programm stattfindet
liegt dieser behörde zufolge im jahr bei
1 zu 700.000 im vorfeld wird es dann
aber auch entsprechende anzeichen geben
der vermieter austritt von gas
beispielsweise oder eine gehäufte anzahl
an beben als ohnehin im yellowstone
könnten als alarmzeichen interpretiert
werden letztendlich würde sich dann wohl
auch der boden durch den magna auf strom
würden bisher ging man also in der
wissenschaft davon aus dass die menge
von flüssigem magma unter einem vulkan
mit der wahrscheinlichkeit einer
eruption korreliert doch möglicherweise
ist das eben ein trugschluss ein
internationales forschungsteam hat jetzt
eine neue studie zum thema
veröffentlicht und zwar im renommierten
fachmagazin nature und diese analyse
stellt unser bisheriges wissen zu der
vorhersagbarkeit von supervulkan
eruption komplett infrage ein zitat
katastrophaler super vulkanausbruch
könnte demnach viel wahrscheinlicher
sein als bisher angenommen
das forschungsteam hatte den supervulkan
toba auf der indonesischen insel sumatra
genauer ins visier genommen darüber
liegt ein scheinbar dänisches gewässer
doch der supervulkan hat gigantische
ausmaße
sein durchmesser 100 mal 30 kilometer
höchstwahrscheinlich ist dieser
supervulkan vor etwa 74.000 jahren
zuletzt ausgebrochen etwa 2800
kubikmeter bimsstein und vulkanasche
wurde zu tage gefördert das muss man
sich mal vorstellen mit dieser menge
könnte man zum beispiel das bundesland
hessen etwa 130 meter hoch bedecken
zudem gelangten damals wohl sechs
milliarden tonnen schwefeldioxid in die
atmosphäre
die globalen temperaturen sanken drei
jahre lang um 15 grad celsius dieser
ausbruch super wird kannst huber war die
wohl stärkste eruption in der geschichte
des modernen menschen homo sapiens bis
vor kurzem ging man noch davon aus dass
diese katastrophe unsere frühen
vorfahren beinahe-aus pilgerstätte
möglicherweise wurden durch den ausbruch
damals die vegetation und die
nahrungsquellen der menschen vernichtet
diese analyse ist mittlerweile
umstritten doch fest steht dass der
vulkan seine spuren hinterlassen hat das
internationale forschungsteam wollte in
der aktuellen studie unbedingt die frage
beantworten
wie sich solch ein supervulkan in
ruhephasen verhält spannend hier vor
allem ob daraus klare warnsignale zu
ziehen sind die einen bevorstehenden
ausbruch vorhersagbar machen dazu wurden
unter anderem die mineralien zu kommen
und feldspat im umfeld des obersee
vulkans genau analysiert denn die
anreicherung der gase helium und aragon
im vulkangestein lässt rückschlüsse
darauf zu wie alt die proben sein können
dazu sagt einer der beteiligten
wissenschaftler martin danne sieg in
einem interview mit sky news mit hilfe
dieser geo chronologischen daten
statistischer schlussfolgerung und
thermischer modellierung konnten wir
zeigen dass das magma noch 5000 bis
13.000 jahren nach dem super ausbruch in
der caldera einer durch den ausbruch
entstanden vertiefung ausströmte und
dann eine platte aus verfestigen rest
manchmal wie ein riesiger
schildkrötenpanzer nach oben gedrückt
wurde wir müssen nun berücksichtigen
dass eruption auch dann auftreten können
wenn unter einem vulkan kein flüssiges
magma gefunden wird das konzept des
aufbrechens muss neu bewertet werden
heißt also im klartext das super vulkane
auch noch jahrtausende nach einem super
ausbruch aktiv ungefährlich bleiben die
risikoanalyse von der die wissenschaft
bisher ausgegangen war ist somit also
überholt wichtig sei es nun zu
erforschen wie sich magma ansammelt und
in welchen zuständen es sich vor und
nach solchen ausbrüchen befindet denn
genau das sei entscheidend um das
gefahrenpotenzial von super wohl kaum
vorherzusagen dazu martin dani sieg das
verständnis dieser langen ruhephasen
wird bestimmen wonach wir bei jungen
aktiven supervulkan suchen müssen um
künftige ausbrüchen vorhersagen zu
können zu wissen wie super vulkane
funktionieren ist wichtig um die
künftige bedrohung durch einen
unvermeidlichen super ausbruch zu
verstehen ungefähr alle 17.000 jahre
kommt es zu einem ausbruch und selbst
wenn es dann zu einem ausbruch kommt ist
die gefahr nicht direkt gebannt wie die
aktuelle studie jetzt zeit noch viele
tausend jahre danach besteht das risiko
weiterer ausbrüche doch fest steht
selbst wenn ernst zu nehmende
alarmzeichen beobachtet werden würden
wären nicht klar welche maßnahmen uns
retten könnten dj logical society of
landen beispielsweise hat in einem
gutachten über supervulkan festgestellt
dass keinerlei notfallpläne für solch
eine katastrophe existieren eine idee
der us weltraumbehörde nasa ist es um
den superpokal zu entschärfen bzw einen
ausbruch sogar zu verhindern und zwar
mit der hilfe eines geothermie
kraftwerks in der nähe des vulkans der
vulkan müsste dafür zunächst angebohrt
werden damit ihm das kraftwerk langsam
aber stetig wärme entzieht und die
magmakammer langfristig abkühlen könnte
doch klar ist auch die idee der nasa
große risiken denn solch eine bohrung
könnte tatsächlich die katastrophe
auslösen die es eigentlich zu verhindern
gilt tickende zeitbombe europa
supervulkan aktiver als bisher
angenommen anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren also wenn ihr das nächste
video gesehen habt dann mit einem
einfachen klick auf den abo button aber
jetzt erst mal dass hier bis dann bleibt
kann